.
>>> IN OUR WORLD HEED TODAY,
RUSSIA CONTINUES TO BULLY ITS
RIVALS ON LAND, SEA AND IN AIR,
AND AS THE KREMLIN PLAYS WARD
GAMES WITH UKRAINE, THE U.S. IS
KIND OF CAUGHT IN THE MIDDLE AND
THE POSSIBLE PUTIN/BIDEN SUMMIT
HANGS IN THE BALANCE.
CNN NATIONAL SENIOR
CORRESPONDENT ALEX MARQUARDT GOT
ACCESS TO THE ELITE SERVICE
MEMBERS AS NAVY ZALES TRAIN NEAR
THE BLACK SEA WITH FORCES AS
RUSSIA AND UKRAINE ARE IN A
STANDOFF.
>> Reporter: A TEAM OF U.S. NAVY
ZALES RIFLES DRAWN MOVE QUICKLY
THROUGH THE PITCH BLACK OF A
WAREHOUSE ON THE BLACK SEA.
>> HERE WE GO.
HERE WE GO.
>> Reporter: LASER SITES
INVISIBLE TO THE NAKED EYE
FINDING AND TAKING OUT ENEMY
FIGHTERS.
>> SHOOTER DOWN, SHOOTER DOWN.
>> LET'S GO.
>> BREAK OUT, BREAK OUT.
>> Reporter: TONIGHT THE DEAD,
WOUNDED AND BULLETS ARE NOT
REAL.
>> HURRY UP, HURRY UP.
>> Reporter: BUT PART OF AN ELAB
RAT SERIES OF NATO MILITARY
EXERCISES INVOLVING ALMOST
30,000 SOLDIERS FROM 26
COUNTRIES.
>> THIS IS JUST SHOWING
EVERYBODY THAT WE HAVE A
CAPABILITY AND WE CAN USE IT
WHEN NECESSARY.
>> Reporter: CNN GOT RARE ACCESS
TO SOME OF THE MOST ELITE U.S.
TROOPS IN THE WORLD, TAKING PART
IN A UNIQUE TRAINING CALLED
TROJAN FOOTPRINT THAT'S ACROSS
EASTERN EUROPE WORKING THE
FORCES FROM SPAIN, GEORGIA,
ROMANIA, UKRAINE AND MORE.
IT COULD NOT COME AT A MORE
TENSE TIME WITH RUSSIA RECENTLY
RATCHETING UP ITS AGGRESSION
SENDING TENS OF THOUSAND OF
TROOPS IN A MASSIVE PART OF THE
EQUIPMENT WITH THE BORDER WITH
UKRAINE PROMPTING FEARS OF
INVASION.
BACK IN ROMANIA THIS DISPLAY OF
STRENGTH AND COOPERATION CLEARLY
HOPING TO SEND A POWERFUL
MESSAGE.
>> WHEN WE ARE STRONG, WHEN WE
ARE UNIT IT HAS A REAL CHILLING
EFFECT ON SHALL WE SAY THE KIND
OF THINGS THAT CAN HAPPEN, AND
SO IN THIS WAY YOU CUT DOWN ON
THE CHANCE FOR MISCHIEF.
>> Reporter: EACH AS RUSSIA
PULLS BACK SOME OF ITS TROOPS
FROM THE LAND BORDER ARE UKRAINE
THEY HAVE BEEN STEPPING UP THEIR
ACTIVITIES OUT HERE IN THE BLACK
SEA.
THEIR WARSHIPS HAVE BEEN
CARRYING OUT EXERCISES.
THEY HAVE BEEN HAD A RATION
UKRAINIAN DEVELOPS AND CLOSING
DOWN PARTS OF THE BLACK SEA TO
OTHER FOREIGN SHIPS AS WELL.
THE KNAVE S.E.A.L.s LEAD THE
TRAINING WHILE THEY PRACTICE
ALONGSIDE THESE GREEN BERETS,
WHOSE FACES WE'RE NOT ALLOWED TO
SHOW.
WHEN YOU TALK TO THE UKRAINIANS
AND OTHERS HOW IMPORTANT IS IT
TO FEEL THAT AMERICAN SUPPORT?
>> IT'S PRETTY SIGNIFICANT.
IT THE SHOWS WE'RE SERIOUS IN
WORKING IN EXERCISES LIKE
FOOTPRINT.
IT IS IMPORTANT NO MATTER WHAT'S
GOING ON AROUND THE WORLD.
>> Reporter: WHICH IS WHY THESE
MASSIVE EXERCISES TAKE PLACE AT
SEA, IN THE AIR AND ON LAND.
>> 50 METERS NORTH, OVER.
>> Reporter: A DYNAMIC DISPLAY
OF PARTNERSHIP AND FIREPOWER
PUNCTUATING THE LOUD MESSAGE OF
A UNIT FRONT IN DOUBLING TIMES.
>> TARGET DESTROYED.
>> Reporter: THIS MILITARY BASE
BELONGS TO NATO'S NEWEST AND
30th MEMBER NORTH MACEDONIA.
THEY JOINED JUST LAST YEAR, A
SMALL COUNTRY IN THIS GROWING
MILITARY ALLIANCE THAT VLADIMIR
PUTIN IS DETERMINED TO
UNDERMINE.
TWO OF THE COUNTRIES TAKING PART
IN THESE EXERCISES, UKRAINE AND
GEORGIA ARE NOT YET NATO
MEMBERS, BUT THEY HAVE BEEN
INVADED BY RUSSIA IN RECENT
YEARS SO THAT THREAT FROM RUSSIA
IS VERY REAL.
EVERYONE I'VE SPOKEN WITH OVER
THE PAST FEW DAYS HAS TALKED
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
EXPRESSING SOLIDARITY